انطلاقا من رؤيه المملكه في عشرين ثلاثين
وبرامجها حظيه ملف المراه باهتمام كبير
دائما وهذا الاهتمام مشاهدينا نتلخص
بتخصيص احد اهداف الرؤيه لضمان زياده
مشاركه المراه في سوق العمل هذه الحصه
وصلت الى حوالي 35% يعادل 35% عاليه جدا
وعلى من دول عربيه كتير على فكره اخر
الارقام تدل بان المراه اصبحت شريكا فاعلا
في التنميه في جميع المجالات الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه العلميه الثقافيه وغيرها على
كل المستويات ايضا مشاهدينا تمثل المراه
اليوم نسبه
34,7% من اجمالي القوى العامله السعوديه
فيما تملك النساء 45% من المنشات الصغيره
والمتوسطه في المملكه على المستوى القيادي
ارتفعت نسبه النساء في المناصب الاداريه
بنحو الضعف منذ اطلاق الرؤيه ووصلت الى
41.1
بالمئه نسبه كبيره
فرو
ه البرارس الانسانيه وال
وثائق التقارير
تنسو الاش
تراك الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات